[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you very much
I love you too thank you and I I know
why you're happy cuz we're back from
vacation and Trump is on his amazing
yeah we were off the whole month the day
come back he goes it's like we're lining
up art cycles but I mean this the
concept of a Trump vacation I mean he
spends all his time golfing eating cake
watching TV tweeting stupid [ __ ] what's
the vacation for him lapsing into a coma
and you know usually we've seen this
over the years when presidents go on
vacation they always the White House
puts out a list of the books they're
going to be reading right you know like
always something fun but respectable a
Tom Clancy novel and then of course a
book of poems by a black lady and ten
books about Lincoln with the Trump White
House not even trying to put out this
list they were like we are the most full
of [ __ ] people in the history of the
world but there are limits when I didn't
get a stroke but he's going partly on
vacation because the White House needs a
renovation it is an old building of
course there are eight people says a
Sports Illustrated writer who heard
Trump say the White House is a real dumb
I mean can you imagine after that later
in their style
I want to tip the ending but it just
galls me I real dumb to call it a dump I
mean maybe that needs some work but a
dump when I think of a dump I think of a
place that's full of rats that's leaking
away
but what is Trump going to learn that
everything he says now he's the
president is going to get out there this
week he had a very bad phone week very
bad week with the phone first of all he
claimed that there were two calls that
happened that plainly never happened one
with the head of the Boy Scout oh did
you see that Boy Scout thing that speech
that's meet was the creepiest thing I
have ever seen a Republican politician
ever do to the Boy Scouts and Dennis
Hastert used to [ __ ] them but but yet
Trump claimed that after that speech
which the Boy Scouts had to apologize
for before Jews for the President's
speech he said the head of the Boy
Scouts called him and said it was the
greatest speech you'd ever heard and
then they got a hold of the head of the
Boy Scouts he said no never happened
don't have his number wouldn't say that
if I did and then Trump said the
President of Mexico called him to praise
his immigration policies they got a hold
of the President of Mexico no not at all
wouldn't do that we keep records
ridiculous why would why would the
President of Mexico praised Trump's
immigration because they had a big new
immigration policy proposal this week
Trump wants to cut legal immigrants in
half what he wants to cut immigration
and a half but don't give him any ideas
[Music]
now they're they want to change the
policy to bring in immigrants only with
skills that American needs you know
engineers doctors Slovak lingerie models
just and then you know his conversations
with foreign leaders they were leaked
this week I don't know that's a good
thing but he tells the President of
Mexico at one point I won New Hampshire
which he didn't I won New Hampshire
because it's a drug-infested den okay
this is so [ __ ] ridiculous I I have
been to New Hampshire it's not a
drug-infested den and I would know
because at my house I have a
drug-infested I actually have
it's my mancave but but then at the call
you saw this one too the Australian
Prime Minister this one takes the cake
first of all Trump doesn't know the word
for refugee he struggle it doesn't
another word for dairy
apparently he's talking about the fact
that there's 1200 Australian immigrants
who are coming here we promised to take
them the Australian Prime Minister is
patiently explaining to this idiot that
were there but they've been vetted by
both the Australian and US security
officials and Trump no a guarantee they
are bad he says they are not going to be
wonderful people are going to work for
local milk people local milk people this
is when the Australian Prime Minister
says put mommy on the phone local
but what let you know let's catch you up
I've been living off a month crisis oh
thank you very much let me catch you up
on what happened with some of the galata
changes at the White House in one month
Sean Spicer the press spokesman out
right Reince Priebus he was the chief of
staff he's out replaced by General Kelly
who was the head of Homeland Security
who's out there and now Rick Perry they
say is going to be in also Eric has been
demoted to Tiffany Garrett is now
married to Kelly Anne and to no one's
surprise Ivanka is replacing Milani also
jeff sessions is still hiding under his
desk and Rex Tillerson will now be
reporting directly to Putin okay so
those are the changes feed van ins
position is still the same bent over
sucking his own [ __ ] okay well that's
not my go through the words of Anthony
scaramouche II who I I never even got a
shot at
this guy was in and out faster than Taco
Bell was like an episode like an episode
of the Jersey Shore where the situation
moves to Washington for a week but
ladies done all that chaos is over now
because Trump is called the military in
general Kelly is on the case he's the
chief of staff now no more this erratic
unhinged [ __ ] that than going on
he's going to find out who's responsible
for that yes the White House has a new
sheriff he is kicking ass he is taking
names everybody's going to look right
now today general Kelley knocked on
Steve battens story said hey quit
sucking in there and get back to work